Hallo Giulia, guten Morgen.
Hallo Sandra.
Wie geht's? Du siehst müde aus!
Gestern Abend ist es spät geworden.
Ich war zu einer Party eingeladen.
Ich verstehe, du hast einbisschen zu viel gefeiert.
Ja, ich habe die Zeit vergessen.
Also habe ich heute Morgen verschlafen.
Und als ich ins Büro gekommen bin,
habe ich viele Dokumente zum Lesen gefunden.
Und E-Mails zum Beantworten.
Erst jetzt hatte ich Zeit, in die Cafeteria
zu kommen und einen Kaffee zu trinken.
Außerdem habe ich in 40 Minuten
eine Besprechung mit dem Chef.
Und ich habe starke Kopfschmerzen.
Oh nein, brauchst du eine Kopfschmerztablette?
Danke, aber ich möchte nur einen Kaffee trinken.
Ja, aber es ist besser, auch etwas zu essen.
Warte hier.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich hätte gern einen
Cappuccino, einen Kaffee und zwei Kuchenstücke.
Danke, Sandra, aber ein Kaffee ist genug.
Nein, nein, du musst etwas essen und dann nimmst
du eine Tablette gegen deine Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe immer welche dabei.
Du bist nett, danke.
Hier ist Ihre Bestellung.
Macht 7,60 Euro.
Danke schön, schönen Tag.
Komm, setzen wir uns.
Wir haben noch Zeit vor deiner Besprechung.
Sag mal, wie war die Party?
Sehr schön.
Es war die Geburtstagsparty einer Freundin.
Sie hat in einer Disco gefeiert.
Es gab gute Musik, viele Leute und vielleicht
habe ich ein bisschen zu viel getrunken.
Aber du solltest nicht so viel trinken,
wenn du am nächsten Tag arbeiten musst.
Ja, das ist wahr.
Aber die Party war so lustig.
Was hat deine Freundin als Geschenk bekommen?
Ihre Eltern haben ihr ein neues Handy geschenkt.
Ein paar Freunde haben ihr
eine Smartwatch geschenkt.
Ich habe ihre zwei schöne Kleider
gekauft, die ihr sehr gefallen.
Schließlich hat sie eine neue Tasche bekommen.
So viele schöne Geschenke!
Weißt du, dieser Kuchen ist wirklich gut!
Hast du gesehen? Dir geht es schon besser!
Du hast immer so viele Energie, wie machst du das?
Es ist, weil ich einen gesunden Lebensstil habe.
Ich ernähre mich gesund, ich trinke
keinen Alkohol oder Süssgetränk.
Ich rauche nicht.
Außerdem trainiere ich oft.
Am Morgen, bevor ich ins
Büro fahre, gehe ich joggen.
Wow, das würde ich nicht schaffen!
Am Morgen bin ich immer müde.
Ich schalte den Wecker immer ein
paarmal aus, bevor ich aufstehe.
Oh, es ist schon 10:30 Uhr.
In 15 Minuten habe ich die Besprechung.
Ich hoffe, du fühlst dich besser.
Ja, ich fühle mich besser, danke.
Ich drücke dir die Daumen für die Besprechung!
Danke. Wollen wir später
zusammen Mittagspause machen?
Klar. Wir sehen uns später.
Tschüss!
Was machst du, um gesund zu bleiben? Ernährst
du dich gesund? Schreib es in die Kommentare.
Und wenn dir das Video gefallen
hat, hinterlass uns einen Like!